[Music]
[Applause]
channing frye killed it last time he was
on with us turner sports nba analyst won
a championship with the cavs turner
sports nba playoff coverage continues
tomorrow night
game six hawks bucks at 8 30 eastern
and you can catch channing on hashtag
nba
twitter live during the second half of
that game
channing thanks for joining us what do
you make of this matchup in the eastern
conference right now
i love it i absolutely love it i think
um
you know i don't know if we've had an
opportunity to watch these
these guys play right i mean at the end
of the day you know injuries are
something that happened right in all
sports i'm gonna see this hawks team
uh go from you know they're they're
pretty good to
holy crap they're two games away from
the nba finals and i'm in atlanta
at no point in my life did i ever think
that we would say the atlanta hawks
are two games away from the nba finals
um and then for the bucks like last
night like i i talk about
how dominant brook lopez was in 2013 and
14
and people actually saw it like he
wasn't doing
anything above himself like obviously he
went crazy but brook lopez is a monster
and bobby portis is good too so you know
we kind of get on the bucks for being
boring
but they got some hoopers like drew
holiday i love i think he's one of my
favorite
top five favorite players i've ever
played against um in a league just
respect wise just what he does and
um obviously the clippers and and sun
series you're just watching guys get an
opportunity
to be in the limelight you're seeing a
lot of these young guys step up
which is uh which is awesome it's that
new generation i just wonder about
giannis no structural damage but to come
back from this injury
there's no way he could do that i've
done it and then we were talking with
shaq last night
it took us six weeks and i'd wear a
brace just to be comfortable
um you know when you stand up like when
you bend your knee your knees not
supposed to bend like that
and then your muscles get stretched out
so even when you're standing up
i don't know if you watch him like you
know i watch little things when you
stand up
like your knee may buckle like that and
it's just like it's the worst feeling it
like cringes your stomach and anybody
that's happened to
unless there's some new type of
technology that i don't know of
i don't think we see him this series um
and then if they do win which i think
they are
i i don't know if we see him for you
know
three or four games into the nba finals
what about trey young's availability for
this next game
i mean listen you gotta look at trey and
be like hey trey
we need we need two games out of you and
this is it
right i mean loan bruises are crazy i
know guys that
try to play through them and you get
maybe 50 so can you win with a 50
tray right and that's really what you're
because at the end of the day the first
and i said this
yesterday the first three plays of the
game told me that the bucks are not
playing around anymore
that they go we are two games away from
the nba finals yeah
right if you were a kid or if you at the
beginning of your career said to hey
you're tr you could have an opportunity
to be two games away from the nba finals
and have a chance even without giannis
you can play a little different
and they started playing a little
different last night like they went to
the rack at will
drew holliday was posting up all their
guards so if you're hobbled
they're now starting to attack everybody
herder bogdanovich
like you know anybody who comes in that
game they're
using their bodies and chris middleton
and uh
and drew holiday i think really set the
tone last night yeah i just wonder
and i know it's easy for me being the
get off my lawn guy
and back in my day these guys would play
hurt i mean these are long
these are big investments i mean the
bucks this is a guaranteed contract the
greek freak has
right um you know 250 million dollars
here
but you don't know if you ever be in
this position again
and that's where i wonder like how much
can we expect
ar i want to be fair to him i want to be
fair to kawhi you know these guys who
have injuries
having had you know six knee surgeries
myself like i understand it
but at some point is it wrong for us to
ask for you to do
a little more given what's at stake here
i think yeah i'm just going to talk
about giannis i don't know kawaii's
situation but
i know this these dudes are some of the
most elite players that sacrifice
everything
giannis has done every single thing
right
like giannis is a good dude he plays the
game the right way
he doesn't doesn't take days off his
teammates love him
he plays with ferocity every single
night
i always look at it as if that was my
son would i let him play
the way his knees buckled right the way
he has
i don't know the the doctor thing i
i understand the the big picture of
yes you're going to the finals but i
also understand the picture of
giannis has an opportunity to be one of
the all-time greats he has that that is
more
important than the now because i don't
want you to go out there
and you're 20 or 5 percent and all of a
sudden something more
happens and then you regret that moment
right giannis you're special like this
is not a finger
this is not you know an elbow on the
other side
right this is not a wrist this is his
knee
and he can't be giannis with
with a knee that is wobbly like a hot
twizzler you just can't do it
are the suns going to be the favorite no
matter who goes in
out of the east i love the suns man i
know i'm from phoenix so i'm a homer
but they play good basketball like
that's what like my son just got into
basketball last week he played lacrosse
he played hockey
he played all the suburban sports and
finally they were like yo you guys start
playing basketball
and i tell him to watch his sons number
one money williams coached me
i think chris paul is still underrated
um and devin booker
now why do you say chris paul is
underrated
well because everyone now is talking
about how good he is just because he
went to the finals i said dude he's been
this good for 16 years
like and i had i'm lucky enough to have
conversations with charles and isaiah
thomas and
we were talking about guys who never had
a chance to win but who were bad
like who were absolutely ridiculously
good in their time
and chris paul has been ridiculously
good in his time
and he's a true point guard right
those things are like you know like
antiques nowadays
everyone turned into a combo guard
because they couldn't get
chris paul they couldn't get that guy
and so between him and devin booker
they kill you on mid-ranges that's
against all the analytics
right so hold on wait what are we not
talking about analytics now because
devin booker dominated like
absolutely he like flicked it off like a
little booger on the table he's like
that i'll get that mess out of here
right so i tell my son to watch him like
all he does is hey
if you're gonna follow me i'm going to
shoot the floater if you're going to
give me the right pull up i'm going to
take this
just take what you can get and at the
end of the day if you could shoot all of
it
you're going to have it sturdy it's easy
it's simple the game is simple and
they just play good basketball and i
think the hawks play good basketball
obviously i like nate mcmillan
um what he's been doing with that team
guys are coming in and stepping in
um you know last night they just got you
know they just got big boyed
but it'll be an interesting game next
game yeah i and we're talking to
channing frye the turner sports nba
analyst he won a uh
championship with lebron james in the
cleveland cavaliers i carried him you
did tell the finals
yeah and then i told him this is you
like this i got you at this point
yeah it's like yeah like i got you here
let me take the rest now
right yeah there's no big guys out there
for me and you know what i've never seen
that story written so i i appreciate you
you're
telling me it's exclusive right here
you're like
very humble that's that's what how often
would you get yelled at by lebron james
when you played with him
oh man um
not as often as you think he's more of a
look guy well jordan would give his
teammates
jordan gave his teammates the look you
didn't want the
looks okay what would make him what
would make him give you
the look lack of confidence
so like if he passes you the ball and
you don't shoot it because you missed
two
he'll look at you like you're crazy and
he goes you don't think i know what i'm
doing shoot the ball
and i'd be like dang yeah you are lebron
so i probably should shoot it next time
it's all encouraging it's all good he's
one of the best teammates i've had
what would he do with ben simmons
channing
okay well i'm just going to speak for
him i tell him to switch hands
like tristan thompson switch hands i've
been saying it since his freshman year
at lsu
i thought that he was a right-hander and
he was shooting
left-handed yeah i mean i feel like
lebron is left-handed and
shoots right-handed and does things
right-handed lebron writes and eats
left-handed
so for me let's start over ben okay
already it can't get any lower because
you don't take
shots so let's work with the other hand
because then it's new it's fresh you
don't have the
you know we used to say you don't have
the yips right on his left hand his
elbow's out his wrist goes to the side
he's trying to like aim he doesn't have
feel so learn how to have feel with your
hand like you got to feel the ball as a
shooter
you got to have like a nice smooth
motion now if you start from scratch
almost like chuck's swing have you ever
seen chuck swing left handed
it looks perfect and then you see him
swing right-handed
and it kind of it was better now but
like then it kind of got a little
chopped
because his mind is used to doing it the
wrong way more than it's used to doing
right
ben simmons is one of the most talented
guys in nba and
the criticism he's getting is only
because of that
right and only because he's a
it looked like he was afraid to not look
cool
right he was afraid to be embarrassed
at his shot or at his thing
to me i just tell ben simmons give me
three spots this summer
give me three spots on the court where
if you go there you'll be willing to go
over 10 over 20 but for us we know
you're working on just three spots
and then free throws just give me 50 34
you could kick that thing in there for
the 34 come on man but
shoot granny style you don't got to be
cool you got to just help us win
shoot granny style is is trash talk a
lost art in the nba today yeah nobody we
were talking about that too last night
nobody everyone gets so personal about
it
because sometimes dudes don't know how
to do it correctly like they really
there's so much information on people
like i don't know if trash talking used
to be hearsay
where now people could wikipedia and
talk about your uncle who
you know end up going to jail for
something you know it's just too
personal
but trash talk is great i think it's
good i think um
but what would you say did you trash
talk
uh only certain times for certain guys
if i needed to i'm a nice guy
like i smile a lot i like life is good
uh you know a long time ago a doctor
told me i was gonna die
and then i played another six years in
nba so i have like a
glass half full all the time attitude um
and so i i needed to be mean sometimes
and when i knew the guy across from me
was really nice
i needed to talk reckless to him and i
mean i literally just
like i don't know cuss him out like he
got my order wrong at mcdonald's
right like just anything any little
thing i would make things up
um you know i think they say bobby
portis imagines that
people slap his mom that's a little
serious for me but you know bobby porris
is crazy but
to me i would just be like this dude
wants to steal food off my table for me
and my kids
and then i would just kind of get mad
that way would you have an
appendix is that uh no no
they thought i had an enlarged heart so
they thought i had cardiomyopathy oh
which is way more serious independence
yes it is appendix has hurt
yeah i had a i had a swollen appendix
appendix for six weeks and was flying
and when the doctor found out i uh he
was like i don't know how you didn't die
or how you didn't get appendicitis i was
like well i didn't so let's get that
nasty little thing out of here
well you had you know chris bosh who had
to go through that
where yeah they just said no we're going
to shut you down i mean there
there have been you know you have hank
gathers you have reggie lewis i mean we
we
we've had these players uh pete maravich
at age 40. they they found out
you know he had hard marcus aldridge
yeah he has to shut it down as well jeff
green
had to get surgery up his chest he'd
open his chest up
scary it's a gnarly scar yeah uh
who do you think do you think there's
any chance lebron gets dame lillard to
l.a
did you see what i wrote i live in
portland so i said dave don't fall for
the trap
if people don't know my humor so like
they're like yannick stop hating i'm
like man i'm just joking right first of
all
i i there's always a chance for
everything
and here's why i think the communication
between your owner
gm coach and star player
should be fluid right and
um i think you're seeing that you're
seeing that in phoenix
that that works right james jones monty
williams chris paul devon booker
are on one page right they bring in the
right guys
they have the right attitude towards the
game there's
just enough pressure to develop the
young guys but to always expect to win
every game
in portland i don't know if that
communication is exactly there now but
we have to wait i think chauncey
phillips is a
was an amazing player who doesn't get
talked about enough he was
like if you were up or down three or
four excuse me
jonathan billis was going to win that
game like they don't call him like
johnsonville
saying big shot after big shot so i
think his communication with players is
going to be great
um i think he's going to get he's going
to hopefully
unlock some of the guys who have been
kind of settling in
um they just have injuries though
chauncey i mean
yeah i mean i mean i i don't know if i'm
if i'm lillard i'm 30 and i'm looking at
all the other great players
and he is a great player but he doesn't
play you know i hadn't had the
opportunity to play in meaningful games
and i just don't see it happening so
where would you have him go
uh i would not let him stay in the west
if on the blazers
i would i i would look at philadelphia
if i thought i was getting equal value
for him and that's not just
we get ben simmons i got to get
something else here
yeah oh yeah you gotta get a lot because
damian littler is the heartbeat of
portland no i know
um you got to get a quote unquote
generational talent that is going to
stay there
right i mean for instance you got to be
like here i'll give you damian lillard
for john marant
like to me that's equal to me that's
equal i know that's crazy to say but
john morant
will stay in a small market and develop
as you go through the rebuilding process
right if you were to get rid of damian
lillard
so who's a young guy that's going to
stay in a small market because you don't
want to trade
damien lillard for ben simmons and ben
simmons is like okay i'm here for two
years
now i want to go to new york or now i
want to go to brooklyn you need somebody
who's going to like
dig their roots into that that's how
rare he is
but ben needs to be in a smaller market
he needs to have a team that's his
like i think part of the problem he's in
philly they expect to win doc rivers
comes in
embiid mvp candidate you know
ben needs to be in a place where he can
play and he can play in games that might
not be meaningful
and it can help him get some confidence
back right so basically if orlando had a
package you would send them to orlando
they're completely rebuilding yeah they
got some young guys yeah and here here
ben
yeah we're gonna develop you and then
you could have ben and markelle fultz
play on the same team together well
i just named orlando it's not like i was
even thinking about their roster i don't
know if i put those two together but
you know i think again yeah i agree with
you ben simmons
is a guy that needs uh like giannis
needs a chris middleton
ben simmons needs to be the best player
or the most dominant player well he
plays different when he didn't have joel
embiid in the lineup
yeah it's i'm pretty sure that doc
rivers conversation went thank you ben i
love your service but we're rolling with
this dude on a nightly basis
and i don't know how that feels because
they've always been oh you guys are 1a1b
now it's like no joel's one two and
three and you're
four in defense but did you ever go to
the line
and like you lose your you were a really
good shooter but
you go to the line and sometimes when
you're not moving
yeah like playing golf that ball doesn't
move and it freaks people out
whereas baseball you're throwing it i
got a swing like we love the reaction as
an athlete yeah but when you get to the
line
everything stops and it's just you
dribbling looking at the basket
yeah did you ever have a moment where
you go
i lost confidence or what the hell did i
just oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
um you know me being a shooter or a
specialist right
i'm out there for one i'm out there for
one reason yeah right
i'm out there to space the floor and my
biggest joke was like hey when i'm out
here
i may not have any points but nobody's
getting double-teamed right you can play
one-on-one as long as i'm out here
because if i get a chance to shoot i'm
gonna shoot it i'm gonna make it so that
was my running joke and that's kind of
the attitude i have
uh towards the game and so for me you
have to always go back to the work
you always got to imagine when you were
you know when i was a kid it was 115 i'm
out there shooting with my dad
on that hot half tennis court half
basketball hoop in my neighborhood
right and i remember those days where it
was like
it was everything and nothing else was
more important
right and then you realize you come back
to that moment where it's like
dude it's a free throw i've done this a
trillion times
like i'm not in this arena it's just me
the hoop and the work that i put in
and you just go shoot it yeah but you
can practice bad habits when i go to
i go to that i can i can hit a hundred
balls
but if i'm not doing it correctly yeah
then i'm not getting any better and i
think
that's ben that's the player's fault
that's the player's fault you cannot be
a max player or somebody who is an upper
echelon all-star
and you don't have there are amazing
elite people to teach you how to shoot
how to break down film
how to dribble how to do all the major
skills to be successful so there's
nobody else's fault but your own
that you don't do it and again i go back
to lebron this man hurts his ankle he
has
20 around the clock care if he's hurt
longer than two weeks
he has somebody change his diet right
because he has a chef he doesn't drive
because he's icing his knees he's doing
this he's watching film
so there's no excuse because what he has
you can do
right these guys are getting 100 200 300
400 million
and you're worried and you can't shoot a
free throw stop it
find somebody who's the best shooting
coach in the world
hire him for a summer have him stay at
your
chateau on the side because you know you
got a firehouse
and teach you every single day create a
relationship with that
person so he's not just there for checks
so he's there for you
and so he can communicate with you how
to be the best you why don't you
everyone has talent huh why don't you do
it
no i don't no i don't have the patience
i don't have the patience
shooting is very simple to me um
obviously because that's what i do and
so people get
they get too much like you got to humble
yourself before the game
right you you know what i felt like i
was one of the best shooters and every
day i would do the most simple
remedial things that the basics
that would help me build out how i
became a shooter
that's the only way to do it and you
gotta humble yourself it's boring
it's tedious and you got to sit there
and do it and you got to do it perfect
and then you go to step two
and a lot of guys want to skip it
because they're talented but you can't
do that
great to talk to you thanks for joining
us it's great yeah of course i
appreciate it thank you
thank you man that's uh channing fry
that's a turner sports nba
analyst and uh he's part of turner
sports nba playoff coverage continues
tomorrow night
game six hawksbucks take a break phone
calls next